good afternoon everyone my name is iming
clay I've been I was comparing a little
bit yesterday I was part of the
committee in setting this conference up
and I'm having a fantastic conference so
fine today I'm talking about a topic
that's in my problem domain I'm a
pharmacologist and I am directly
involved in doing preclinical and
clinical drug discovery today I'm going
to lead you through some of the problems
that require computational attention and
also make a case for Python and its use
in this particular sector the first
thing that I wanted to outline is that
it's a really big part of the UK economy
we actually get a trade surplus from
pharmaceutical and chemical activities
that you know about five billion a year
as a global trade it's a some 250
billion dollar industry and in terms of
spend on R&D budgets here in the UK this
was somewhat wrong when I put it in my
original slide but we spend about a
third of the UK's R&D budget if you add
it all together goes on to
pharmaceutical research there's a lot of
money that's spent in finding new drugs
and then as a job sector we are
predominantly made up of scientists and
engineers it's a heavily technical area
this pie chart simply gives you an idea
of roughly how that split occurs the
dredges of the talk are to introduce you
to preclinical clinical drug discovery
it is quite unlikely that any of you are
involved in preclinical clinical drug
discovery is that correct can I have any
hands of anyone who is actually actively
involved fantastic so now we are so
about 1% I'm going to demonstrate some
of those computational aspects my role
became to be the the systems architect
effectively for the company involved in
collecting data storing data processing
and making reports out of it I know
exactly how I'd like my analysis to
occur and i learnt software programming
in order to be able to do that and the
case that i'm trying to make is that for
python to be used in this particular
domain it broadly isn't used in this
domain i shall hopefully point out why
it isn't there isn't a particularly good
reason why it is not used but i shall
explain that later so preclinical drug
discovery unlike things that you'll
probably see when you see topics on a
technical
or computational nature mostly focus on
the early part finding chemical
structures doing simulations with those
very very low level stuff before we have
any idea of what the drug is in the
first place but preclinical drug
discovery is focusing on testing the
drug inside of cells and mammals it is a
somewhat dirty industry perhaps I know
that in creating software in the rest of
it we live in a very sort of sterile
hygienic sort of environment where we
just can work at our computer and
everything's lovely an abstract and the
rest of it my personal area is finding
out whether a drug actually works inside
of a living organism and the two things
we want to know is whether a drug
actually works and we call that efficacy
it's an idea of how longs it take for
the drug start working how long's that
last for where does it focus on is it is
it better than my competitors drug those
sorts of questions and the other second
thing we're concerned with is toxicity
does the drug have an acceptable adverse
side effects it's a simple truth that
all drugs have side effects merely
because the the way that chemicals work
inside of an organism is a careful
balance usually between one or two or
many various outcomes it to the point
that there is a principle within
pharmacology of doses solar versi set
venenum which is simply only the dose
determines the poison in fact you won't
be able to actually pass a drug I'm
quite sure with the FDA or the emirate
or a unless you demonstrate it has some
side effects because it's a
straightforward is there isn't a drug on
the planet that doesn't have a side
effect it's a straightforward in
invertible fact so the farms to do your
case for using python is in the in a
state of doing signal analysis and
classification this is classically an
area that where we do a lot of work with
matlab simulink it's very much the
dominant tool chain for using that
python as i come to show you is more
than capable of doing these things it's
just not used so often and the one that
I'll be distributing is is to do with
ECG and I explain that a bit later the
other part is statistical NASA clinical
data sets clinical data sets and disk
analysis in pharmacology is mostly done
by using SAS that tends to be the
dominant thing it we are very large
industrial users we
SAS cuz that's what big industrial users
use and then the last thing is
documentation according to regulated
ontology and ontology is nothing more
than a control set of terminology for
describing things in your particular
domain such that blood pressure we would
have an ontology for systolic blood
pressure that's an ontology for saying
what is the maximum blood pressure in a
given beat of your heart so the first
thing going to talk about is ECG
analysis how do you do that with Python
well the case that we had was that we
have this particular drug that we've
developed up to phase two so if shown it
does something we've shown it works at a
dose we've shown some toxic side effects
they're not as bad as the actual
therapeutic effect so it's a drug and
we're very excited about it we're
basically waiting for this thing to
become acquired because what we don't
want to do is go on to then develop it
because we're a biotech company we're
not a big pharmaceutical company the
drug itself demonstrated herg blockade
and hug is a gene it's it it stands for
human III Go Go gene which of course
means absolutely nothing ether a go-go
means that if you give a fruit fly that
doesn't have this gene ether it goes
nuts and it simply means that that it is
not obvious what it actually does but
ago a blockade of herg leads to a block
of the inward rectifying potassium
current now you need this thing on every
single beat of your heart what it does
is it rectifies the potential of your
heart with every beat I'll show you a
little graphic in a minute to explain
exactly what I mean by that but that's
the thing that often gets blocked and
the blockade of that causes an
elongation in between two particular
fiducial points on the ECG which we can
measure and we can use it as a
predictive indicator of whether a jokes
gonna cause cardiac toxicity a prolonged
QT can lead to this particular event
called to size depois which is French
for twisting at the points which is a
fatal ventricular arrhythmia you die in
about two minutes if you have that the
ECG is a continuous periodic waveform
and if you were choosing of bio signal
to analyze ECG is about sort of grade 2
it's kind of in the mediate level sort
of bio signals then the easiest one if
you fancied analyzing a bio signal would
probably be a blood pressure
which is just a sine wave that goes high
when when your heart is just pumped in
them pressure is high and low when the
blood when the heart is sucking the
blood back in an ECG can be broken down
into its periodic components and there
are a number of markers on that ECG that
we're interested in the ones that I have
mentioned is this interval between the Q
and the t now it doesn't necessarily
there isn't a hard and fast rule as to
which people use but most people we use
the peak of a cue and the peak of the T
because it's a excuse me it is a clear
marker to use the trick here this isn't
this is an idealized stylized ECG is
this baseline can wobble around and the
hardest thing is trying to work out
exactly when this T peak finished as I
as I mentioned earlier this is how the
ECG relates to the electro activity of
your heart this is a gift from Wikipedia
and when it gets back to the original
I'll explain it
okay so first of all electric action
potential starts than sin arterial node
ghost the atrioventricular nose slight
delay goes down the bundle of hiss to
the apex if their moves reality
ventricles your ventricles contract
that's your systolic blood beat and then
this last bit is the rectifying current
this resets everything so you can then
go on to a next successive beat the
point I was making earlier about the
drug is that it blocked that last
rectifying component if that rectifying
component doesn't happen your heart
isn't ready for the next beat and if at
a certain point your heart's going to be
able to deal with that it's
fantastically resilient but at a certain
point it will overlap with the next beat
and that's when it goes out of sync as
soon as the heart goes out of sync
bloods not push around efficiently and
yeah it's a vital concern to analyze the
ECG there is a standard set of tools
that we put in place I'm sort of fairly
sparse with my code in this because this
quickly becomes an advanced level talk
if I'm talking about signal processing
obviously jeez I'd like to get the point
across of how we use Python hgf ISM is
the data format that I have standardized
all of the data that we used in Verona
farmer on that's partly because it's
extremely good for keeping very long
series of data you can have a random
access to various parts of it and when
you're analyzing a periodic waveform you
can go through a chunk at a time and
then sub chunk each ECG signal within
that longer signal and it's a very
effective and efficient way the other
part about hdf which is fantastic is it
stores your metadata alongside of it and
being able to keep your data and your
metadata indella be bound together is
particularly important so once you've
managed to get your data and you brought
it in smoothing becomes the next larger
point I haven't gone on to describe
smoothing methods because there are so
many and it read appends on what you're
trying to look for broad in what you're
trying to do is remove the lower
frequency components there'll be a
baseline drift you want to smooth out
random noise after all you're measuring
the ECG by putting sensors on somebody's
chest they're going to be picking up
electric electrical signals that are
coming from around them from static
electricity from their clothes and
smoothing can be used to to get you to a
nice clean ECG the ECG i showed you back
here has been smooth somewhat you can
see there are some quantization
noise and there are a few sort of square
peaks on it but that's a largely smooth
signal otherwise you'd see lots of noise
the next part is how you find the our
peak so let me quickly take you back
here the our peak is this very large one
in the middle this is the easiest thing
to find on the ECG and to do that I do
it with a really simple method I I say
that the our peak is going to be at
least ninety percent above the main line
of the signal and you move a window
through the signal I've condensed this
down to be using a mirror method called
fine peaks and the way that it does it
is simply windows along the signal and
when it gets the threshold it continues
along until it goes below the threshold
you have two points which define the
peak must be somewhere between that I do
a quadratic interpolation I draw a nice
curve and the maximum point of that
curve is the peak of my our peak and
that works pretty well that's like
ninety six percent ninety-eight percent
effective at doing it there is a whole
conference dedicated to how well you can
analyze the ECG if you're really
interested in ecgs I recommend looking
at the computing in cardiology and
conference series they know a great deal
about how to get 99 percent 99.999% etc
etc once you've got your our peak you
can then scan backwards to find the cue
peak and then you can scan forwards to
find the T peak and that's effectively
how I find it once you've got the time
difference between those you can then
start doing your other parts so it's a
mention slice forward find the maximum
the peak and then my method for finding
the end of the T peak is fairly
straightforward I user I find the TP and
then regression down and when it meets
the baseline I consider that to be the
TN peak as I say there is a whole body
of literature devoted to trying to find
the end of that T peak but at the very
least as long as you can get some
measure of it this makes a lot easier to
measure a very long ECG trace the last
thing we have to do is we have to
correct the Qt for the heart rate
because that ECG is going to construct
and contract and expand as your horror
goes faster and slower the QT rate that
difference in that queue and the TP is
going to change and occur the linear
relationship and this is the one noted
here so it goes as
e so this is as the heart rate increases
your QT shortens sorry that's the time
so yeah as it shortens the QT shortens
and it's in this particular relationship
and what we do is we correct one for the
other and traditionally how this was
done is by simply taking the square root
of the of the other heart rate and then
cutie / that it's not the best method in
fact you're allowed to submit it using
this method this is called Bassett's
method correction it was originally done
because QT correction you to be done
well before we had a lot of computers
doing a lot of things in pharmacology
and the way that is preferred by the FDA
is to correct each QT for each
particular beat you have and if you
consider in the space of an hour where
you might take an ECG trace someone's
heart is beating maybe 60 times a minute
it's they were doing this manually it's
not really that useful so how long an
automatic method does it is impressive
it allows us to get a very very tight
correction the QT interval of a correct
idea the QT interval after all if the QT
interval increases in a way that implies
that our drug is called in cardiac
liability or if we correct it and we
over correct it or under correct it and
it implies either more or less liability
there are serious consequences for
getting it wrong you have people having
ventricular arrhythmias which could
ultimately kill them so python helps you
analyze the ECG partly because it's no
more difficult in MATLAB you do the same
sort of techniques inside of MATLAB but
you can do the inside of Python it
supports many of the the basic routines
are inside the the libraries that are
part of that scientific stack the
quadratic interpolation you can find
inside of scifi being at a slice along a
signal and having a data structure which
can do vectorized operations on series
is all built into numpy there isn't
anything particularly difficult more
difficult and doing our matlab and that
comes from someone who's use matlab for
the past eight years most commercially
to g analysis tools are big gooey things
partly because the people who are using
them don't do any programming I'm
what of anomaly as a pharmacologist in
that I like doing programming and the
problem is with those commercial tools
you get very poor scripting maybe one or
two of them have visual basics
integration to new in visual basics
which doesn't work particularly well
there isn't any support for vectorized
operations to everything is dog slow you
just don't the I guess we'll cook versus
that is you get very poor end-to-end
workflows so once I've got my I've
classified my signal and I've got my
data maybe won't make a report a bit I
end up in a copy paste he'll basically
and that's very common and it hasn't
really changed and the last bit is that
if you want to break out that domain
specific tool are you GUI say you wanted
this so that someone could send their
ECG trace to a server server does the
system puts it up on a web page it's
extremely difficult to do that you can
make web pages with matlab it's just
very painful indeed so that was easy
geez and how you can use Python it's
just glass of clinical data sets is is
fairly more straight forwards and a
clinical data set as an object is large
ish the set of Records and it's maybe a
few hundred megabytes maybe gigabyte in
size you know you probably all want my
job there's no real date of problem
requirements you can fit the whole thing
in RAM be copping around like anything
and you really don't hit any performance
problems we don't really have I would
argue in the pharmaceutical industry a
big data problem we have fairly small
data sets but at the same time when
you've got maybe something that's you
know 820 columns wide 30,000 rose it's a
bit painful to do in Excel but people
still do so that's kind of our issue is
that the the next step on there is 2s2
use Python the main thing that we do is
we pivot on a number of these axes and
report so in a particular clinical data
set sorry that is a bit difficult to see
you have a huge list of parameters in
here I've got things like calcium the QT
interval Alamy nana transferase all of
these things have indications for
various organ systems may be problems
with your liver problems with your lung
problems with your heart and any time I
want to be able to plot a trend line
compare that trend line to somebody some
other subject maybe I want to compare it
to
time of day because all of these values
shift depending on which point of the
day that we're in and invariably that
task is pivoting on that data stacking
and reshaping your data which you can do
in Excel you can make a pivot table but
by the time you're making a hundred a
thousand pivot tables it just doesn't
work it's just very very painful to do
and the last thing is everywhere ever
which is abbreviations everywhere and
the problem we have is that because it's
such an old because we've got such an
old way of doing things and because we
have software that really only allows
maybe a bite for the for the description
of a particular statistics we have
abbreviations everywhere the the formal
documentation on which ontology is you
should use for describing things in
clinical trials is 500 pages it's it's a
very very long document indeed and this
is something we can help get around with
Python original why I did is I I rolled
my own bandhas I think as most people
probably did but of course unable to
release it because we're not in we're
not into the habit of releasing stuff
for open source and there's a subclass
the wrecker a which is inside of numpy
and then using things like numpy unique
to get all the different categories
within a particular column and then
stacking the data based on that and
stacking and unstacking and doing all of
those parts it wasn't particularly fast
but it was a lot faster than doing it in
a GUI and now of course we use pandas so
while pinus is very popular course and
the financial sector for doing time
series in the rest of it it's also
incredibly useful for doing clinical
data sets there isn't actually anything
else that I use there's better than
pandas for doing that which which which
is somewhat amazing the way that you fit
that together is you import your data
frame from somewhere and the pivot table
allows you to build up the coals and
columns and the rose the way that I
would then build this into a larger
script is you can take the intermediate
parts of your pivot table you can get
sort of ordinarily that table we want to
maybe stack on subjects and then within
each subject stack on each trend line
but maybe you want to flip it the other
way you can maintain those intermediate
steps as you go along with pandas and
that's particularly effective both in
memory but also in speed
and grouping by these various pieces of
data is is all of the game in doing
clinical data analysis sub selecting
your data is the eighty percent problem
that we have in the pharmaceutical
domain the abbreviations everywhere or
otherwise known as clinical ontology as
we call it is you get used to after a
while in many ways what you're paying
for when you buy a pharmaceutical
statistical programmer is they're
familiar with all these various ways of
abbreviating things and it kind of
offends Python esters and it bends me is
because it's just very implicit it's
theirs you know it's very hard to see
what's going on because they'll
abbreviate a sentence start time of
blood pressure after calibration and
it'll be SBA SBA be right you know
there's no way of understanding it and
the way that we've we just used python
is and I know this is simple like
dictionary map those ontology is to a
formal description of it but you just
don't have that when you're doing it in
other systems they don't this idea of of
having that as part of their repple
method so the dunder rapper Method is
just phenomenal for us to use because
you can put all those information inside
of it have a small function that says
describe or in fact in ipython you can
overload the ? when you want to write a
particular function ipython you're not
sure the parameters are you can suffix
it with a question mark and it tells you
what it is and that's basically what I
did for us so you have all the
statistics all these abbreviations you
do that I would say this is this this is
used like that and a description of the
parameter as you were doing it
interactively amazingly quick much
quicker than reading a PDF that has all
more listed so helps you because as a
metric liquid datasets are just a little
bit too large for XL they're just on the
border and most people just put up with
it they have they're not we're not in a
big data even medium data size problem
so no one has the impetus to learn those
additional skills but at the same time
if we if we took it on if we took on our
burden of using something with just a
little bit of programming this task
becomes a great deal easier it's a fully
fledged programming language but the
same time it's got the repple which is
fantastic the interactive analysis
the easy syntax the syntax is as easy as
matlab and that's very important for
those who work in sciences who were not
programmers we use programming's as a
means to an end a little bit as Gail
sort of Illustrated this morning but
having a fluidity and using syntax is is
very very important it's what makes
Python a compelling toolkit for
biological and pharmacology prefer
pharmaceutical scientists it limits the
spawn of spreadsheets because the way
that we would get round this is we would
save the intermediate pivot table in a
different sheet or in a different Excel
document and it would just it gets out
of hand very very quickly and but that's
what we do and this is actually a if you
were doing a start-up and you wanted to
do this in the pharmaceutical sector
having a way of rationalizing Excel
spreadsheets that have been sprawled
because we don't use programming
languages you'd make a lot of money
because that is a big part of the
problem is how we store it and how the
fact that none of us in pharmaceuticals
and pharmacology get taught about data
structures and taught about how to
organize our data and because things
have shifted so quickly to being so
heavily data-driven and computational
base we have this morass of unstructured
problematic data and the last part is
that stats model part integrating with
psych it's is that I used to clean up my
data in pan in Python move in something
like our to my analysis or move into
sass to do it but if everything's
integrate together then the toolchain
can flow end to end and that's enormous
for being able to get efficiencies the
last part of my talk is talking about
documentation according to these
regulated ontology is this regulated way
of talking about what we're talking
about very self didactic I did that by
converting the documents as Fink's now
most of you probably used Fink's for
documenting code projects but it's
phenomenal for documenting a submission
that I would submit the FDA or the MHRA
to register a new drug to be used on the
on the market the way that I did this
was converting word to HTML that was a
fairly rigid format I could use clearly
HTML elements using HTML tidy and
various associated toolboxes lxml was
very useful for being able to work with
that using pan dock convert it to rest
and then generating a contents from
using a fold structure because the
folder structure itself was worked quite
well for doing this with my colleagues
to point out how our documentation fits
together we have these documents which
will have these big triangles of how
data should be organized and logged and
categorized and regular submissions must
all follow that format they follow this
thing called the common technical
document which is a really stupid name
for the document in the first place
because that's so generic you wouldn't
know that was based on a drug submission
and Sphinx has these roll names which is
nothing more than a variable a parameter
that you can put you can embed inside
the documentation but in terms of having
something that's visible but you can use
to parameterize parts of your document
it's just phenomenal so you can hook
then to the build process which the next
part is thinks is that as far as large
document compiling services go spinks is
about as easy it is to understand I had
originally started building a system in
latex which would generate it and you'd
use a simple markup to generative thing
you wanted and sphinxes the only one
that I know of hooking in my custom bit
of code to make this work better for a
drug submission that was easy enough for
me to do it's really rapid to make work
the features / farmer is that we have
multiple targets when we submit our
document it's a very large PDF document
i give it on a CD to the MHRA building
here in London it's as old school as
that at the same time we have an
Internet where we we observe all the
stuff so having it so that you could
targai HTML was brilliant for being able
to show possible licensees our
documentation it's very easy just a
fragment off a part of the document and
sandbox it just for them because at the
same time our industry is entirely based
on intellectual property we only let out
a certain amount of information to are
either regulatory agencies or our
competitors because without that they
could very easily build products to
compete against us so that is partly the
mindset of our industry it's searchable
is hyperlinked which is just great for
being able to look through it and as I
mentioned the role names help you add in
regulatory requirements into your
documentation race simply
it's important that you can customize
links to your domain and the last part
is that directives control the
repetitive macro contents if I want to
pull things in run a script which redact
certain things so key one of the key
words when you're writing a document
life sciences is the word significant
this finding was significant according
to this p-value and what we had there is
a directive that would search through
and check of where significant was used
and whether we were using it which
context it was being used in because
those the words that an analyst or a
competitor will pick up on to see which
parts it is effective on so the last bit
of their talk is what's hot in Python
back has these it has compelling use
cases I could go on for a day talking
about stuff that you could use Python
for in pharmaceutical industries and the
main parts is it I think it can be
summed up in this one sentence its
inertia regulation having someone to
blame the first part is that we are
really culturally slow to change and the
reason we're slow to change got loads of
cash we don't have to change there's no
impetus for a dot new stuff we're also
because of that slowness we love stuff
that costs a lot of money you know SAS
license like 3 grand for a single you
know user license we love throw-in
thousands of pounds of software and we
silo ourselves into our industry I
invited a number of members from the
pharmaceutical colleagues and they don't
come along to a conference that isn't
farmer this drug discovery that because
we see ourselves in our own particular
bubble and we have the means to remain
in that bubble this concept of
simplicity is that we all use office
documents everything is written in word
done in Excel so of course we use
SharePoint to use our CMS but keeping
everything and share points a dog to try
and program against having spent a few
years writing against it compared to
what you can do in Python regulated
companies want regulate solutions so if
your company isn't selling a piece of
software that says we are compliant with
21 CFR part 11 we don't care you know we
just you know there is nothing and it is
nothing more than maybe a few test cases
maybe an insurer a statement of quality
that says this is I either company
say that this is a tested piece of
software and unless you're talking
semantically in our bubble we don't
listen and then liabilities and Leo
conformity largely holds us back from
doing open source stuff that's involved
in critical decision making we can use
it for doing prototype ink doing tests
but we rewrite the stuff into Java and
we use Oracle's life science framework
to build it in and it's rubbish it
doesn't do anything that you can't
really do in Python and you wouldn't
know this unless you were someone like
myself who knows the problems I mean and
you do programming and you know the pain
points but I'm all about solutions
that's you know there are these big
reasons why we don't have it but here is
my quick slide on solutions to fix the
whole industry first of all is a bit of
social engineering we're just terrible
at listening to new developments new
technologies and the rest of it we have
it to be packed up and sold to us
exactly how we want it or we don't
listen the best part is probably target
biotechs rather than Big Pharma the the
way the industry is structured is that
we have these smaller groups we call
biotech firms let me have one product
that they're developing and if it if it
succeeds maybe they become a big
pharmaceutical company maybe they get
acquired they are the equivalent of a
startup company in the in the in the
biotechs in the pharmaceutical sphere
then much easier to to move around I
worked for a biotech and I was allowed
to do whatever I liked because I was a
one-man development team and then you're
going to target big farmer and a big
farmer you could define as one that has
8 10 20 projects you know a market cap
of a few hundred million yeah they're
very stuck they're very large industries
they're like government they're like
healthcare they're very very slow to
move because they've got so many parts
to them the third point and I spoke
about this to a number of the groups at
term app icon in the u.s. earlier this
year is the idea of a certified Python
nothing more than a declaration that
says this is certified for use in this
particular industry it's a statement a
guarantee of quality it is a
an insurance claim it's saying in the
event that your code doesn't add one
plus one equals two then I am liable
that it doesn't add one you know one
plus one equals two the plant is used in
so many things that are not necessarily
critical no one died is necessarily if a
lot of you know python bits don't work
but work in high production environments
it works in the financial sector which
you can lose a lot of money very quickly
if things break this this would this
would accelerate the use of Python in
those industries is that sort of
certification and the last one is a
legal entity that ensures that so that's
kind of the other part of the previous
point is that if there was an entity
that said yeah we guarantee that this
won't divide by zero and break all these
things or give you numbers that are
wildly different within specified
tolerances which again probably sounds
like it's not a difficult task we'd do
this already we build stuff against
specification it's nothing more than
meeting a specification and whether
that's the the body of the you know of
Python itself the psf or maybe it's you
know a commercial group like continuum
which says we will ensure these versions
in our packages all together that helped
a great deal in regulated industries we
are very cautious with very conservative
need someone to make guarantees that we
can we can blame fine I'm at questions